hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from the super bet chess
classic this is round five and it's the
bogdan daniel dak versus alireza first
uh being the local hero uh if you
remember from the previous video where
we covered his game i mentioned that he
uh went undefeated in the 2021 edition
of the uh feed a uh grand swiss where he
got six draws and three victories
against very very strong opponents and
so far he played four uh games in this
impressive tournament and he got the
draws against nepal arunan and
mavidyarov and he defeated rapport in
the game that we've covered
and now he faces alireza uh so that has
the white pieces it's quite the game
let's check it out so here we have d4 uh
knight to f6 pilot is a c for g6 going
for the king's indian defense knight to
c3 bishop to g7 and e4 now so this is
the standard
standard stuff uh d6 with bishop to e2
alireza castles and now there are a
couple of very very uh popular options
here for example knight to f3 and bishop
to g5 are the absolute top moves that
are that are being played here uh you
can also play f4 which is somewhat rarer
you can play g4 which is a very rare and
you can play uh h4 which is extremely
rare and that's exactly what doc plays
and he says i'm not afraid of you
uh he's uh lower rated than most of
these players but not not by much he's
like 20 not 26 75 i believe but i'm
going to check i don't want to trick you
guys uh yeah officially he's 26 71 uh
before he
started this tournament so uh you know
it does make sense to go aggressive
against these top players if he wins
that's a lot of points plus if you lose
i mean yeah you only lose a little but
um you didn't really have fun so here h4
he wants to go right for the for the
black king and now uh here the the well
the usual reply here is c5 even though
this is very rare
i guess c5 is considered the absolute
strongest alireza goes for knight to c6
and okay this uh puts pressure on
white's center
invites d5 now challenges the knight
here knight to e5 and now h5 so
what's happening here of course we want
to advance the pawn all the way and then
put
pressure on black's dark squares around
the king we have c6 alireza response to
this aggression on the king said in a
very principled manner he wants the
counter attack in the center we often
say when you are attacked on the king
side or queen side you should counter
attack in the center of the board that's
how chess works uh and here h6 knight to
f3 is a known move here but h6 right
away is a new one so already as of move
nine we have a completely new game let's
see how alireza handles this pressure of
course bishop to h8 this is the only
move knight to f3 now and now not
capturing but rather knight eat the g4
you could just capture for example
captures capture the bishop d7 you
continue development uh but alireza
wants to play a fun game
uh so knight eight the g4 putting
pressure on the f2 upon you and now
queen to b6 could be a very very
unpleasant uh move uh we have castles
and now queen to b6 and now what do you
play here uh this isn't all that great
for black but it's a heart uh
uh hard to realize why and here after
some consideration doc played queen to
b3 the the uh probably strongest is
knight the a4 or even a4 preparing a5
then proving that the black queen does
not belong on b6 and after a5 we can
play knight to e1 attacking the knight
here and after the knight moves now we
play bishop to e3 we attack the queen
and now probably you have to move the
queen back and white retains a better
position because if you grab the b2 pawn
then uh we have a lot of fun here rook
to c1 and we will trap the queen it
seems very unlikely but uh it's true how
do you how do you uh save the queen uh
none of these squares are available to
the queen uh and uh after something like
knight eat the g4 going after the bishop
bishop to d for now uh preparing all
sorts of nasty discoveries we're gonna
play c5 now uh attacking the bishop and
after rook the b1 there really aren't
all that many great moves here you're
gonna have to capture uh the rook here
uh because if you play queen to a3 we're
going to play knight to b5 now attack
the queen and after queen to a2 now
comes rogue b2 and that's it no more
squares for them for the black queen so
queen to b6 is questionable uh but it
requires if you don't know this by heart
you're not gonna
find this so here queen to b3 and knight
to h5 now opening up the dark square
bishops diagonal here uh we have knight
to h2
and neither player wants to of course uh
capture because if you capture then if
you capture here then you allow black to
open up the h d a file for the rook and
of course if while it is a captures then
of course the dac will open the a file
for his rook so here at knight to h2 uh
offering uh a trait here and you could
play something like knight captures king
captures then uh of course you don't
want to allow bishop captures knight
we're going to bring the knight back
something like bishop to g5 of course
you could play like this uh but elitist
just goes back knight h to f6 now we
have knight back to f3 and now knight to
d7 shifting this knight over to e5 we
have queen to c2 and the knight might
also come to c5 this will come with
tempo then on the queen here so knight
to c5 putting pressure on the e4 uh pawn
but okay the pawn is sufficiently
defended but white cannot play b4 to
kick away this knight from c5 the queen
prevents this uh bishop to f4 and now we
have a5 so you don't have to worry about
b4 anytime soon rook 8 to e1 and now
alireza opens up the position with f5 we
have e captures rook captures and now
bishop to g5 putting pressure on this e7
pawn so queen back to d8 and now comes
queen to d2
uh here uh in interestingly a bishop to
d3 although it looks incredibly
impressive attacks the rook and also the
uh e7 pawn uh it's not all that
impressive we're just gonna play knight
captures on b3 and now uh what do you
play uh the problem is you have to play
queen captures on d3 and that's why it's
not all that scary if you had bishop
captures an e7 it'd be great but there's
nine captures on e1 a nice in-between
move going after the queen here and
after rook captures we're going to play
queen to d7 and not much to show for
black is just completely winning here so
after queen to d8 queen to d2 and now we
have queen to f8 uh putting more
pressure
along the f file bishop to d1 now
finally going after that e7 pawn and
rook to f7 already has to defend it and
now comes pawn to b3 and here uh
interestingly knight the e4 is
incredibly strong for white uh to give
you an example knight captures an e4
rook captures an e4 and now what can uh
what can black play here uh well black
could go for something like let's say
bishop to f5 we're going to attack rook
and after the knight moves uh what what
does black do next it's just
very very tricky we're going to play
rook to e1 we're going to put pressure
on that e7 pawn and that is a backwards
pawn you're not going to be able to
advance it so it's going to be very very
hard for for black to withstand this
however after rook to f7 b3 was played
and now we have knight captures on h6
now idea being of course that if bishop
captures an h6 we're going to play
bishop captures on c3 attack the axe
queen and after queen to e3 uh or if you
capture of course queen captures an h6
but probably queen to e3 and now bishop
back to g7 and alireza is very happy now
but instead we have d captures on c6 b
captures on c6 and now comes knight to
d4
again uh this knight being here is just
super annoying as long as this is here
uh we can we're never really threatening
to pick up the knight on h6 so here
knight to a4 would be the way to go now
we are threatening bishop captures an h6
h6 and after knight g4 we can just
double black spawns here and this will
be of course very good for white for
some reason alireza uh doesn't uh
doesn't like doug doesn't like this uh
here we have knight to d sorry knight to
d4
uh putting pressure on the c6 pawn and
here i think alireza was very happy that
uh
he gets uh uh
you know a little breeding room here and
he goes knight to f5 puts pressure on
the knight here and he uh allows uh of
course doctor capture on c6 and he does
he plays knight captures in c6 here at
knight captures on f5 was
uh probably more precise after bishop
captures the bishop f3 now we go after
the c6 spawn uh you know
maybe better do it like this but in the
game knight captures and c6 was played
and now alireza plays bishop to b7 he
gets uh grabs hold of this long diagonal
bishop to f3 and now comes uh rook to a6
ball it is and this is the first moment
where uh alga could really have seized
the initiative but it's uh it's a very
tricky move to find uh the the idea here
in the position is that uh h6 will win
you the game but uh i mean uh not not
something you would uh you would see
point is that once the bishop moves back
bishop to e3 we're going to play queen
to c8 attack the knight here and now
after knight to d4 we're gonna play
bishop capture sunday for bishop capture
sunday for bishop captures on f3 and
after g captures knight to h4 and
alireza has a winning attack here the
rook and the knight are attacking f3
queen can come to h3 this is just
unstoppable so probably after this h6
move you can't really even go back with
the bishop
but none of the other
options are are any better i mean you
can play knight captures on e7 with
check we're going to play knight
captures bishop capture 7 rook captures
and uh
well
black is just uh black is just better
here rook captures queen captures we can
even trade any everything queen captures
queen captures a bishop captures queen
captures and now you get this position
uh where alireza is just up a piece uh
so of course not uh not a lot of fun for
white uh holidays i played rook to a6
instead he went for the knight here and
now we have knight captures on e7 with
check knight captures an e7 bishop
captures and b7 bishop captures on c3 we
have queen captures and knight captures
on b7 so a nice capture fest uh here uh
uh at move 29 and uh uh okay uh there's
still material advantage here you can
see that alireza is up a piece but it's
not as clear a game as the one that
we've shown so here rookie two uh adding
more defense here to the f2 pawn h6 now
uh and uh bishop all the way back to c1
we have rook to a8 uh and now comes
bishop to b2 uh threatening queen to h8
checkmate so king to h7 the queen now
guards the h8 square rook f to e1 now we
double up here knight to c sorry knights
to c5 and the queen to d2
and now uh here we have knights to a5 uh
and queen to d5 so now you can see that
it's not easy and alireza is much much
better so here we have h5 uh bishop to
c3 and now knight to d7 we have rook to
e6 without putting a lot of pressure
here but
rook the c8 and now
we have bishop captures on a5 dac says
all right i've calculated something very
very
uh
unpleasant for you uh do you have an
answer here because if not i have a past
eight pawn i have a pass b pawn those
you as you know are incredibly fast uh
however alireza's position is completely
winning here so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the only
winning move for alireza while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
rook the c5 wins the game even though
it's not all that
easy to calculate and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show of
course it's rook to c5 alireza did not
play this but we will show why it's
super strong so
of course you are attacking the queen
and the bishop and if the queen moves
we're going to win the bishop unless you
play queen to d2 so this is one thing to
consider the other thing you have to
consider if you play rook to c5 is what
happens if rooked
e8 is just a very very uh nasty idea
but it's not a problem we're just gonna
play rook captures on the on d5 here and
after rook captures an f8 we're going to
play rook captures on f8 c captures on
e5 and now rook to 8 let's say we go
after the bishop if the bishop moves we
pick up the pawn and if b4 uh okay we
just continue playing this but black is
completely winning here there is uh no
no discussion here uh the other thing
and why i think alireza decided to go uh
not to go for this is queen to d2 we
simply defend the bishop but now alireza
missed knight to e5 and this now traps
the rook there's no way for the rook to
be saved queen to c8 will pick up the
rook
but i think alireza saw even this uh
it's uh what comes next that he missed
and this is the real uh shocking one uh
bishop to c3 we're gonna play queen to
c8 of course we go after the rook and
now bishop captures an e5 uh queen
captures an e6 and now bishop to d4 now
you see that the rook is attacked so
we're going to win back material and the
queen is attacked but here comes the
move a queen captures an e1 with check
that's the good stuff queen captures any
one and of course knight captures on d4
and now the knight and two rooks will of
course defeat the the lone white queen
even with the past a and b pawn it's
just a completely winning position for
black so very very
tough for alireza that he missed this
but he had only 30 seconds on the clock
and he still needs to make two more
moves to reach time control so you have
to reach move 40 uh in classical chess
or
you know from tournament to tournament
but i think in you know feed a regulated
tournaments it is always 40 uh to be
granted additional time so he did not
have that time to calculate he played
knight to f6 attack the queen now comes
queen to d2 and now it is much much
easier for white to play we have rook to
e8 offering some trades uh bishop back
to c3 and now rook captures an e6 we
have rook captures and knight to d7 now
so alireza can still put some pressure
uh but it's not as clear as uh as it was
a moment ago so here queen to g5 uh goes
after that the g6 pawn already that
defends it with a queen to g8 now comes
g4 uh h captures ng for queen captures
and now knight to e5 attacking the queen
queen h3 check and now knight the h6 you
have to play this move because if you
move the king let's say king g7 then we
play rook to d6 and that's it how are
you defending this knight the king is on
g7 if queen to e8 we just attack it
again rook d5 and if rook to e7 now of
course just bishop captures an e5 rook
captures and a queen to c3 again how do
you defend king to f6 now comes f4 and
that's it white of course completely
winning here so after queen h3 check
knight to h6 alireza has to go for this
now comes rook captures on d6 and now
the ack has three connected pass pawns
on the queen side uh does this uh change
uh
the game character maybe a little bit
but
we'll see
we have queen to e8 uh defending the
knight here and queen to e6 now offering
a queen trade but also putting more
pressure uh on the knight on e5 rook to
e7 defending queen to d5 and now knight
e back to f7 we have rook to f6 uh and
now uh comes with rook to d7 attacking
the queen queen to e6 and now rook to d1
with king g2 and here alireza after
considering the position for a while
decided to trade queens because after
queen a6 check queen c6 just the blocks
uh check and that's not a lot of fun
yeah you you know have to uh trade here
uh because if you capture on a2 of
course then uh well there's a lot that
we can play but uh well even rook
captures on f7 is possible followed by
queen to f3 let's say captures with
check captures queen to f3 attacks the
knight attacks the rook here uh you fall
apart so uh queen captures an e6 was
played we have rook captures on e6 and
now knight to f5 and now we have this
end game where alireza is up a piece but
it's uh three connected past pawns so
rook to e1 immediately going for the
trade all it is are the clients rook d3
we rook the c1 defending and knight to
g5 now so two knights and the rook so
close to the white king as good things
might happen for alireza but uh none of
them
neither of them are uh you know good on
time uh alireza has some three minutes
on the clock that has some five minutes
on the clock so king f1
knights the e6 in the now comes bishop
to e5
uh rook to d2 going after the pawn here
and now b4 dark starts pushing the pawn
and gives up the a2 pawn because there's
no good way to defend the pawn actually
uh for example rook to a1 we're just
going to play knight c5 and you can
never push this pawn because the b3 pawn
hangs you can never i mean it's uh it it
will be impossible uh to push the pawn
so if you play something like b4 then we
play knight the d3 attacking the bishop
attacking the f2 pawn and that's a lot
of trouble so instead b4
dark starts pushing those pawns rook
captures on a2 now comes c5
rook to a4 and c6 so we're going to give
up the two pawns at
advance the past c pawn rook capture sun
before c7 knight captures alareza has to
give up the knights that prevent the
pawn from uh reaching the promotion the
the the promotion square rook captures
with czech king
uh sorry king uh went the g8 and now
comes bishop back to g3 and now after
all is said and done you can see that
it's equal material uh and there is not
much either player can do about this
rook to a4 was played king g2 we have
rook to b4 and now rook to a7 we have
rook to c4 king to f8 now comes uh
rook to b7 and the players start
repeating king fade rook to a7 king to
g8 we have rook to b7 king to be a king
to f8 and rook to a7 and he was in this
position on move 68 that uh
and already
agreed to a draw as there is nothing
more uh to be done here so crazy crazy
game uh duck really uh went uh went for
uh for alireza's king already very early
on you can see that the pawn is already
on h6 uh on move nine uh very very
interesting stuff alireza had a had a
few moments where he could have uh won
the game that h6 move okay
no one really can calculate that it was
an incredible uh incredible game but for
someone who came to this tournament as a
2800 uh great things are expected of
them uh and also that rook the c5 move
that was uh well
it is of course would have no problem
calculating that if he had more time on
the clock he had 30 seconds when it
happened and that's basically the story
of this game so a great great stuff by
by bogdan here really representing
romania well
not allowing any
anyone to to take a point away from him
uh just brilliant brilliant stuff so he
he faced five incredibly strong players
for draws one victory i think that uh
he already won like 15 rating points
that's incredible stuff so we'll see
what happens tomorrow is the rest today
so no no just tomorrow of course we will
cover at least uh two two games i would
say one from today maybe one from
yesterday as i didn't cover all that
many of them uh so we'll see uh you can
always use use hashtag suggestion to
suggest uh one of your favorites uh so
yeah and that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank a
long thing wrong thing derek king jason
salaya uh claudia bravely and alessandro
bossi and yogesh patki uh donating
because this is the strongest move for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event until
it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day